[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum uh
thanks for making this podcast your
choice for this week i know you get a
lot of choices folks there's a lot of
choices out there but you keep this
little podcast going if you're here for
kim coates i appreciate you if you like
the podcast subscribe watch on youtube
where could where what are the handles
for the twitter and the instagram uh the
at inside of you pod on twitter outside
of your podcast on instagram and
facebook that's right so join join us
and if you want to join uh patreon
become a patron
and uh support the podcast in more ways
than one it really helps go to
patreon.com
inside of you
uh happy to be here ryan uh it's been a
crazy couple of weeks dealing with a lot
of anxiety here i'm trying to get it
under control
some days are better than others and uh
just uh trying to work it out trying to
exercise every day trying to get my life
in order here
and remember to breathe apparently
that's a huge thing
i think we forget to breathe don't we
set a timer on your phone and that says
breathe yeah everybody just remind her
to breathe make sure you breathe uh and
uh if you're dealing with anxiety and
all that stuff you know talk to someone
talk to someone uh better help
or you know anyone else you think you
know that's uh they're they're a sponsor
and they're great and you use them a lot
of friends use them it's better help um
hey i just want to shout out to the
animal rescue mission my good friend
shira who has created this animal rescue
mission the animal rescue mission
rescues rehabs finds forever homes for
abused and neglected animals go to the
animalrescuemission.org
animalrescuemission.org and press donate
you can donate there also if you want to
donate foodonfoot.org the homeless
situation is awful
they could use your help the ronald
mcdonald house los angeles
can use your help in echoesofhope.org
for foster youth
and uh helping them out so that's always
amazing uh you can also go to the uh
inside of your online store if you wanna
get any merch there's always great merch
the small scripts to be signed i have
the lex miss script you know that i
autograph and that's a big seller i've
got these zip ups these inside of you
zip ups i've got inside you glasses and
mugs and tumblers and
lex luthor pictures and lunch boxes lots
of great stuff so go to the inside of
you online store and uh the new band
sunspin might well not new band it's my
second album with sunspin the new
album's coming out so be sure to follow
us on twitter and instagram sunspin band
and sunspin.com if you want any cool
merch
you can also book a show with us you can
book a zoom with us there's a lot
uh that's about it really i hope you
guys are having a fantastic week and uh
we'll be giving shout outs to all the
top tier patrons at the end of the
podcast
that's always a favorite of mine to do
kim coates
i knew him on smallville we worked
together i had a blast i love this guy
i've known him for a long time sons of
anarchy
the list goes on he's done tons of
movies got a movie coming out we'll talk
about everything and he doesn't do many
podcasts
um and i think he did call me babe a lot
or no michael he said michael a lot he
calls me michael a lot michael let me
tell you michael
and uh i love him he's uh he's a treat
he's a joy to have on the podcast i'm
lucky to have him and uh let's get
inside of kim coats
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
cozy makeup
you look great
so do you with all that hair oh all that
sexiness thrown around look at you
you're the one with the mane look at you
you got all this good hair at your age i
mean how the hell do you do it i'm 117
michael i don't i don't know how i
[ __ ] did it i took i took some of
your your pills back in the day when i
met you i'm superman you were all bald
and beautiful and young and funny as
[ __ ] oh my god that's how we met we met
on smallville you were agent carter on
some folks he wasn't just on sons of
anarchy and bad blood and the new movie
neon lights but he's done tons of movies
but he was on smallville
come on michael how when was that bro do
you have any 2007
2007 just before the sons of anarchy i
was i was up in vancouver and they
offered me i don't know i think two or
three shows or something like that
and almost all my [ __ ] was with you i
mean it was
it was so fun we did we had a lot of fun
i remember you just being so like i
wanted to know you i wanted to be your
friend
i liked you i was just like this guy is
great he was just great to be he had
such a great energy about you
and what do you remember by the way what
do you remember about smallville i
remember you had a sore back i remember
you
you were fighting through some pain i
remember you were the funniest guy on
set by a [ __ ] million yards they had
big sets there i loved vancouver
um i don't remember much about the guy i
played
i know i had short hair and i think i
was clean shaving
i think so yeah i think
and i knew this i knew that you were on
a
a huge hit
like michael you learned
the thing we all need to learn about
television before i did i mean i was
i was that movie guy always movie movie
movie i would do an arc on shows like
yours a csi miami things like that but i
never wanted to be a regular in a tv
show i just thought no i'm not gonna do
that i'm i'm just gonna keep doing my
movies and be broke sometimes why was
that why was it did you have what was it
about tv
i don't know i i don't know i just
remember in those i'm older than you so
i started before you and i remember in
those late 80s early 90s i went from
stratford playing you know the youngest
macbeth ever john neville directed me i
was yeah 20 john neville
yeah i was 28. and then new york these
new york agents saw all my work and said
you got to come to new york i was just a
canadian kid obviously still am proud
i'm american now too proud but
somewhat but
but i'm pretty proud of being canadian
and so i went to new york
and it was all theater and i did
broadway i was stanley kowalski on
broadway for five months on the square
yes hollywood hollywood discovered me so
michael i
i was just a movie guy because that's
what you were supposed to do
and then television i think
i'd like to ask you in your opinion but
for me
when you know gail definitely did the
sopranos and that sort of mid-90s cable
tv it just started to explode for me
yeah it became like shooting little
movies every week
yeah but it's got now i have you know i
sound like i'm a 90 year old guy but
don't you think that it's gotten a
little out of hand there's so many
streaming platforms there's so many
shows do you like this
michael i michael i'm i'm doing this for
you because you're a star because you're
my buddy because your podcast is
exploding because it's a great thing for
me to do and i get to see you selfish i
get to see you i don't watch anything
rosenbaum nothing i don't
i don't watch anything i swear to god
i'm i'm i'm a [ __ ] zipper head i
i i i'm so busy i'm working all the time
i'm flying here and there me and my wife
diana we're still together with a
goddamn 38 years with your wife
come on michael what the hell i mean how
all right i want to get into that
because i don't know how the longevity i
mean 38 years nobody survives in
hollywood and you guys have survived it
yeah we have but you know yeah but you
don't watch breaking bad you never saw
game of thrones
did you all right do you watch yourself
sometimes what what do you love about
yourself what shows you go hey i was
pretty good at that i like no i i say
that all the time but no no no no no
michael
i mean did you know that theo rossi and
i had are doing a podcast called reaper
reviews did you know no
yeah so folks pay attention
no no at the beginning at the beginning
of uh the pandemic 2020 when the whole
world stopped right you know what the
hell was going on at least for me and
i'm sure for you and for everybody i
came running up to canada to my i've got
a few spots here and there and
everywhere and i just hung out theo
rossi calls me in like april may of 2020
when there's nothing going on and he
goes we should do
a reaper review
and review sons of anarchy every single
show and i went no
what do you what are you nuts there was
92 seven i'm not gonna do well we've
done it
we're actually on the last show which
we'll record next week
of two and a half years of talking once
a week that the fans have gone nuts for
it bazooka brains bananas off the rails
so i'm doing that once a week and
michael you know how hard these podcasts
how hard you work how hard we work i'm
not complaining but i had to watch
every single show of sons which i hadn't
done when we did it how many i'd only
seen i'd only seen maybe a third of them
right maybe 40 of the 92 so when you
start reviewing you got to look at it
and take notes and then you know we
still sound like idiots we don't know
what we're talking about theo and i but
we've got a gazillion viewers now and
it's just been exploding and just in
time for me to say goodbye next week
yeah
uh it's funny you say that because tom
and i who was clark kent on smallville
we started a re-watch podcast uh two
weeks ago
and so we watch every episode over like
you guys have been doing and then we
critique it and kind of go and it's it's
crazy to watch yourself
so many years ago and
critique it and critique the show and
have guests come on and talk about this
yeah
do you guys do that too you have guests
on we we do now you did a lot more than
us you were in the hundreds right we did
uh i left after season seven i did 165
and then tom did more i think he ended
up doing 220 or something episode so i
if we make it through that show through
the entire run i have to watch three
seasons that i wasn't in
and that's gonna be [ __ ] tough
that's gonna be really really hard i
think you just make tommy look at those
by himself and you just be there for
comic relief
yeah exactly what do you appreciate
though watching now
watching all these episodes back what's
one thing that you've learned
i i now get it
i i get what a big hit it was i mean i
i didn't really understand the whole
like before
sons michael i was oh you're you're the
guy from black hawk down oh you're that
guy from open range oh you're the guy on
goon the last boys yeah the last boys
you're that guy but then you do
a show like sons for me
and the the level of what a hit that
thing was and what a crazy show it was i
became kim coates so i i think after
watching the shows now that theo and i
have done i now understand the
incredible fandom that we and you know i
don't know if you know this michael but
sons is one of the only shows ever that
our our our ratings never went down they
they only went up like up and up they
never plateaued they never they just
went up from season one to two all the
way
so fx is the biggest hit they they've
ever had by a gazillion dollars so
pretty proud of all that smallville
definitely had its highs and lows i
think there were some lows at times and
then one season got better than this
season was worse but you're saying i
mean we did a lot more episodes but
still at the same time you did 92
episodes and the trajectory of success
just went up
when you were doing smallville
it would remind me was it every week you
weren't binging yet right back then
right it was once a week it was once a
week there was no binging you had to
wait
yeah so i think that's part of sun's
success in a way we only did 13 every
season and when it opened in september
as always that's you know early
september
10 o'clock tuesday night it just you
know for the next 13 weeks if you were a
sons fan
you never missed a tuesday night and
then you had to wait
seven or eight months before the next
season so it was just talk talk chatter
chatter so i think that's one of the
reasons why our show just continued to
climb and build because
you know
was it was it exhausting did were you
did you work every day were you
constantly like oh my god i'm exhausted
like you know like what were your days
like hey you know michael you you i'm
sure you're the same i i i'm allowed to
complain cause i'm old now but i never i
never took for granted how how much we
worked or i never complained yeah it was
some really tough days we
we you know we're all in leather and
riding those bikes and those harleys and
we shot in like july august september
which you know in l.a is really really
hot and we we called it we called it
doing the timber
at least once or twice a week we go
timber
man down
one of the crew would just [ __ ] pass
right out gatorade infusion of gatorade
because it was so freaking hot
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon hold on to yourselves here folks
if you haven't had a taste of magic
spoon you are missing out every time i
talk to any of my friends about magic
spoon
they rave about it this is a great
cereal magic spoon has created a cereal
that we can eat as adults and kids it
doesn't matter who you are you're going
to eat something that's healthier than
when we were kids when it was all sugar
and all crap
and you had to give up cereal the thing
we loved as kids
but you don't have to do that anymore
not with magic spoon i mean uh who
doesn't love cereal ryan the the crunch
the sweetness the way you can
accidentally eat a whole box or sneak it
as a midnight snack
and
magic spoon has truly innovated and
changed the game with sugary cereals
they spent time to perfect the crunchy
texture and develop an astounding
variety of flavors so that they always
hit the spot but without any of the
things that are bad for you magic spoon
packed with protein and a great healthy
snack for just about anyone whether
after a workout during a hike or at
midnight when the cravings strike
there's a flavor for everyone from the
richest chocolate to the sweetest honey
nut
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four to five net grams
of carbs in each serving and it's low
carb keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free and only 140 calories a
serving there's really no excuse build
your own box with a huge variety of
appealing flavors like cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry muffin
maple waffle honey nut cookies and cream
and cinnamon roll oh yes and it's so
easy folks just go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try the magic for yourself and be
sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident
their product it's backed with a hundred
percent guarantee a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked who does that
they know what they're doing they're
confident remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this podcast
now a word from our sponsor better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
that's how our brains work so why don't
we treat them that way
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and care into keeping them
healthy there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain learning a new
language or taking power naps there's
also better help online therapy better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions it's more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside
you were in leather and you were riding
motors did you have to learn to ride a
motorcycle for sons of anarchy or did
you already know how to do it no there
was only three of us who could ride mark
boone jr
david labrava and myself of the leads
knew how to ride some of them lied and
said they did and then they fell a few
times and realized well you're a liar
so they all had to go to bike school
jesus
everybody and i would say by the end of
the seven seasons charlie hunnam
probably became the best rider because
he was never off his bike he rode to
work every day we all did but he really
did and uh
yeah i know he became a really good
writer so yeah i know i knew how to ride
and i i was called safety first michael
because i would stop so many shots i'd
go cut
cut flanagan why are you rubbing your
[ __ ] feet on the ground because my
boots are slippery well you do that
later wait deal why are you zipping out
of the other line you got to stay caught
cut so they were really pissed off of me
but at the end i got a little trophy
from everybody calling safety first
probably saved a lot of lives when
you're on a harley there's no [ __ ]
around as you know it's it's the real
deal were there some big accidents on
set we had three
yeah we had three we got lucky ronnie
perlman went down hard you know ron i
know him from conventions
yeah he he he's the best he's really
cranky but i love him he's so was he
cranky on set
uh
sure i mean
the the first he looks like he's frankie
right
but the last couple you know when you
know you're gonna die or you don't like
the writing or yeah he became cranky but
i think we all had a bit of crank in us
yeah right but yeah i know he went down
hard and and i was right beside him when
i got off my bike like a horse i just
got out so fast told him not to move not
to move lay there lay there
the ambulance came and he turned out to
be all right a lot of lesions and
scrapes and then mark boone jr booney
we could have lost him we were doing a
scene we were chasing the russians of
course we were chasing the russians why
wouldn't you be you know who wouldn't be
and so we're chasing the russians and he
had this
old
late 90s harley with these ape hangers
really tall it was really hard to
negotiate and navigate is a tough bike
to ride and he's a great rider and we
went around a corner too many rocks and
he slid and he slid hard and he missed a
big big boulder and uh
he was up for a couple days and then
tommy yeah i could go on but we we were
all right no one got seriously hurt we
were very lucky right
take me back how it all started because
i mean were you since you were a kid
growing up in canada did you want to be
an actor is it something you always what
were you what were your parents doing
what did they think about how did it
start how were you popular in high
school
sure you were
yeah well i don't know sure i was always
a bit of a a bit of a leader i think i
was you know the captain of the hockey
team wow i was a captain football team
in high school i was the best player and
the worst team in saskatoon's history we
we only had 540 kids at our school and
we had grade nines all the way to grade
12 on the senior team we just got killed
on the football field but i took a lot
of
took a lot of hits and i gave a lot of
hits but look
i i'd never seen a play in my life
michael
i was
a pretty good little redneck kid for
sure sports board sports did all right
at school did okay
and then uh when i graduated high school
i knew i wanted to be a teacher i want
to be a history teacher i was gonna go
to you know education university of
saskatchewan so i took a drama class for
fun as an elected i said i'll pass that
class for sure how old were you not a
girl huh how old were you
19 19
19 and then i want to hear your story
but i'll get i'll get this over with you
no i want to hear it please i go to
school
and uh you know i take this drama class
because while i'll pass it there'll be
lots of girls and
and then it hit me man i don't know what
what the hell happened but i'm i'm
reading ian esco and tennessee williams
and shakespeare i didn't even know what
a soliloquy was
and before you [ __ ] knew it
i had done 25 plays over four years i
switched my major from history to drama
in year three got my four-year degree
we're doing summer stock every year i
made no money
zip all my buddies were getting me
through school
i get them through everything now they
don't they haven't paid for anything for
20 years but
but back in the day man in those early
80s when cozy was going to university i
knew i needed to be a professional actor
and that's how it all started i moved to
toronto and the rest is history what
were your parents thinking when you told
them you wanted to do this mom and dad
joyce and fred great question dad fred
and who joyce brett fred fred and joyce
yeah
fred frederick and joyce yeah mom's
still alive oh good uh she's 92. wow uh
pop passed before sun started so he
didn't get to see any of that stuff but
he knew all my work he's pretty proud of
me
um good guy you would have loved my dad
you love my mom good people no listen we
came from a really small house in
saskatoon
my two little brothers and me they're a
year and 10 months younger than me
they're twins dale and dean of course
they're dale and dean and you know we
were just playing hockey and sports and
and living the life in saskatoon and you
know people go how'd you survive the
winters and i go well you either live or
you die when it's minus 40 either dress
for it and live or don't dress for it
and get frostbite and lose your fingers
i mean it's pretty it was that cold
there huh well
up in canada i just sleep for you
michael
i was born in new york but i grew up in
indiana small town in indiana from the
time i was eight on all right well you
didn't get the coldness that we did we
got cold but it wasn't like that it was
the only other city i remember is moose
jaw saskatchewan
where the hell is moose jaw saskatchewan
yeah this chest close to saskatoon right
so did you have a background of theater
yeah did you
tell me well i studied i studied in you
know i was a nervous wreck like i am now
and i was in high school and finally um
i was taking drama class and i took it
my freshman sophomore junior year just
because it was an easy a and you just
had to goof around and the senior year
my teacher said hey you got you gotta
audition for a play if you're gonna take
advanced drama which is the same as
drama every year and i go oh my god
and i audition
for greece
and i got the part is hey hey this is
the main brain vince fontaine spinning
the stacks to wax here at the house of
wax waxx cruising time 10 26 sharp
shooters pick of the week are brand new
and shoot up the charts like a rocket by
the belle dew braid and i just went on
and i loved it and i got it and i
remember i told the story i think the
last one the last episodes but i
remember a popular kid came up to me and
i was not popular shortest kid in my
school and said hey you're really funny
last night
and that changed everything it just
showed me that oh not being me was the
way to go be someone else be an actor
and uh and it just took off from college
i started doing tons of plays in college
and sort of
fell for it was the only thing i felt
like i could do
and the camaraderie and being around
people in the green room and although
look there's a lot of clicks as we know
in the drama department i mean
everybody's judging everybody
everybody's talking [ __ ] about so and so
why did he get the part and he's like
you know um but i stuck with it and you
know i went to new york afterwards did
off off broadway and you know the rest
was history
i was so happy yeah
but you did a lot of stuff you did like
you got accolades big accolades
well i don't know about i don't know
about that but i i certainly stumbled
into some pretty pretty juicy plays and
parts i mean i
you know in the third year university we
went to edinburgh for the edinburgh
drama festival and we won a fringe first
which is a first place for a play called
creeps about cerebral palsy david
freeman wrote it a canadian
writer back then play writer and it was
a huge massive hit
so we came back from that and i knew you
know
that's it i'm being a professional actor
and then when i went to toronto like i
told you we took it took a while i
waited for a couple years you know i
waited i was with a big agency and gary
goddard you know that typical smoking
cigarettes eating way too many
hamburgers in his office
big guys cigars smoking just [ __ ] you
know he said we're gonna turn you into a
movie star like now and i'm like no no
you're not
no you're not because what do you mean
because i want more theater more stage
anyway no no i said no no that's and i
stuck to my gun
huh i feel like all [ __ ] stage actors
say that same thing like no yeah i just
want to do theater until they're somehow
forced to do it but michael i i didn't
say i didn't want to do film i said to
him i'm not ready yet i need to be a
better actor
and so we did man we i did 11 plays in
halifax
um i did streetcar for the first time
that's why
when when i anyway so long but then
stratford
two years at stratford then
new york discovers me and i'm on
broadway and i'm doing dracula in
atlanta
i mean my god rosenbaum i think i got
between five and ten phone numbers a
night from women what
from playing dracula at the alliance
theater thirteen hundred seats
now
by my powers of most red black
my bonds of blood and i would take
wilhemina and i would pull right up to
me and i would crawl on her like a
goddamn lizard and there was blood
everywhere and i'm sucking on her and i
we were right at the front of the stage
our heads off no people were screaming
women were losing this [ __ ]
um i went coughing i insisted on
you know making sure that we rehearsed
at night time
i would go to strip club after strip
club to get the get the whole thing it's
just about the blood it's not about the
body it's about the blood in my head
doing my little method [ __ ] so
yeah i had long fingernails long black
hair it was it was a hit how old were
you
uh
that was like 1988 so i was 30.
and you were already married at this
point oh yeah
where did you meet your wife uh met her
in college in university she was 18 i
was 19.
she's obviously way smarter than i could
ever pretend to want to be
um not that she's with me but just she
can see right through me and see right
through so she's let me michael
do my thing like i give diana all the
credit in the world for raising my two
beautiful daughters and giving me the
freedom to be kim coates she's not
jealous she's not worried she you know
we fight once in a while obviously it's
a roller coaster how how can how can it
not be you know we dated for seven years
before we got married so i've been with
her forever but
the separation has kept us wanting to
come back to each other you know when i
go away from movies or yeah black hawk
down was five months in morocco and i
didn't come home once you know so
don't you talk to her every night or did
you talk to her here and there she
doesn't need that she knows you're doing
your thing and let you do your thing do
you think that's what's kept you
together is that she just appreciates
you you appreciate her and you let each
other do your [ __ ]
and i and i i look up to people who are
who are you know with another actor or
another artist it's tough to do diane is
a former teacher you know she she she
could stop teaching because she wanted
to once we had kids and if we were lucky
enough to make enough money that's what
she wanted to do is be a homemaker and
she did it so well and she helped the
kids with schooling and what was the
first movie role that you took
ah
wow the first one
i took was with nick cage what first
time you do a movie it's with nick cage
yeah i had no lines though it was like i
was at stratford it was a two-day part i
got paid 600 a day it's most money i
never made in my life
um it was called blue boy it was about
this rower this or rower from canada in
the early 1900s famous book so and so
nick played that guy and i remember
talking to him a little bit
and at lunch nick had this salad
that was as tall as you
michael it was on his plate and it was
just a salad
and he had steamed chicken on the side
and he said
and i started to really learn about
the the incredible stamina and willpower
it takes to be a movie star if you want
to be in shape
you can't you can't fart around the
camera sees everything right you know
that yeah so yeah i had no lines i had
six lines they were all cut i was on a
little wagon watching them race making
bats being a big better that was my
first movie no one no one saw it no one
cared about it but was that after that
you had that itch you just kind of felt
like i like this i like being on set i
like i want to be a movie star i i had
this feeling of
um
it's different
it's different than stage it's
you you gotta do it again
and again
and continuity you know i was drinking
and they said you gotta drink at the
same line like [ __ ] that i never thought
hitting your mark you know with the
camera and back then that was 35
millimeter boom you know those were yeah
those were today we got all these red
cameras all these we're all on tape and
it looks amazing but you can just burn
that down
right
very expensive in the olden days
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
inside of you is brought to you by
patreon
yes the inside of you
patreon we're supporting this we're
doing a little ad for it just thanking
everybody for supporting the podcast and
if you want to support it a little bit
more you can just go to patreon.com
inside of you and become a patron i'll
message you back after you join might
take me a few days but i'll message you
back there's different tiers some people
get boxes of merch from me every couple
of months uh sometimes there's zooms
there's youtube lives with me where you
ask me questions there's bonus stuff
there's content there's you could have
your name shouted out at the end of
every podcast there's so much and most
importantly it really helps the podcast
so just go to patreon.com
inside of you and become a patron today
when was your first movie
um i think it was
i did this little independent movie that
was just terrible i don't even need to
talk about it just it looks so bad that
the dp must have been on crack shooting
it but it was with a lot of really good
actors it was it wasn't a terrible movie
it was just like man to pete dan
futterman uh wow
it was it was just it was a little movie
jennifer garner
and it just but it looked like [ __ ]
wow i mean i i all i remember about this
movie was god why does it look so
terrible
uh and then the first real movie was uh
midnight in the garden of good and evil
clint eastwood directed me and it
brought me out to california and what
was that that was like 97
and uh i remember i auditioned for that
and uh i didn't even know what i was
auditioning for i just put on an accent
the southern draw and uh i went back my
agent goes hey you got a call back for
midnight in the garden of good and evil
i go mid in the garden of what what
and they go yeah um
and i went in there and the casting
director said hey clint would like to
see just a little more subtle and i go
whoa wait wait hang on a second
clint eastwood's watching this he's like
yeah he cast from tape and i go oh my
god and the next thing you know i was
flying to savannah georgia and you
[ __ ] got the party i got the part i
remember i went the producer picked me
up from the airport took me to set and
introduced me to clinton goes just he he
knew me just walked us michael i just
want to say if you do what you did in
the audition
i'll be very happy
and i [ __ ] my pants right there and it
was just like oh my god i'm working with
clint eastwood
come on it was the best feeling ever is
it true about him that he doesn't do a
lot of takes is that true dude he goes
i remember i had this i remember him
just going he'll just come up and go
i'll acknowledge the jury on this one
i go okay he goes well how do you feel i
go i felt pretty good how do you feel
clint he goes i felt great you want
another are we good i'm like well i mean
i mean that was the sort of attitude
when he said he didn't say action he
would look at his uh jack green as dp
and goes he'd look at me and go michael
and i go
thumbs up and then he look at me he'd
make that rolling thing with his finger
like jack
and they would and everything would
start moving and they would go one or
two takes
i i and i saw him i told the story i saw
him get a little annoyed with kevin
spacey one time i saw him get like you
know everybody's annoyed with him anyway
at the time kevin's like yeah look i
don't know if i should be coming in
through this store or this should i
acknowledge it i don't know god damn it
do whatever you want
just for a second he just lost his cool
i don't know what the hell ever you want
to do kind of
like oh my god it was just it was price
have you ever
been star struck on a set where you're
like yeah when yeah i'm gonna tell you
because first of all that's [ __ ]
brilliant i can listen to you doing
clean all day long you [ __ ]
um
i gotta be i gotta be honest i mean my
my boy bruce willis he's going through a
lot of
different times right now and i feel for
him and big hugs to him and his family
and
i miss him i really do anyway but back
in the day when bruce was
he still is
he's a [ __ ] massive movie star yeah
and
bruce my first hollywood movie was the
last boy scout so
you know
you talk about auditioning right so i'm
i'm you know i just finished broadway's
streetcar and
things are taking off and all these
casting people marion dougherty the late
marion doherty
she said you're gonna be a [ __ ] star
kid and here we go and she got me this
audition for the last boy scout
there's like three scenes and i remember
going on tape for her in new york
and that's back in the day this is early
90s 91 maybe and they flew you out they
flew you out for an audition they put
you up
i had a real audition with tony scott
the late great tony scott oh genius he's
gone now too and
phil silver and we're sitting in this
room a really small [ __ ] room and i'm
doing this audition and
i walk out of the room and the casting
chick comes out it wasn't mary and it
was the la equivalent marion stayed in
new york and she said hang on hang on
and so i'm in the hallway and tony comes
busting and goes yeah yeah you got it we
got it i went i got it
and i said you're offering me a [ __ ]
chat he goes oh yeah yeah yeah it's in a
couple weeks so i go back got the part
now you got to hear this
so true story i uh i go to set
and it's back in l.a and i know if you
remember the last boy scout but it was a
football team dude i loved it i remember
you just stole the [ __ ] out of that one
scene too yeah yeah yeah yeah so we did
that scene later my first scene
was at uh we're getting a newspaper and
damon wayans comes to get a newspaper me
and my two thugs we walk up when i say
someone he doesn't look too tough to me
he doesn't look too tough so the scene
was i end up punching him right in the
face right
and so
i get to set
and i'm in my wardrobe and my shoes that
they've given me are super slippery like
they're [ __ ] slippery as [ __ ]
and i'm sliding all over and i i was a
little and i'm in a little honey wagon i
don't even have my own bathroom i'm like
completely green right i got nothing so
but i've got this big movie so i go can
we and they go no no just get some
coca-cola pour some cocoa in the bottom
you'll be fine you'll be fine okay so i
get to set i meet the stunt guy we go
over the punch
it's going well
it's time for the punch
and the punch goes pretty good
and tony comes up everyone's there
willis isn't there yet i haven't met him
yet but everyone's there
and tony comes up and goes okay right
mate we got that we got that we got that
now now this is one more one more go
just go for it we got it it's all done
we got it but go go i go
all right
so we do one more action
he comes up we do the thing
and i punched him right in the face
my back foot slipped michael and my my
fist went farther than it should have
and it hit him right right underneath
the glasses he had sunglasses on
the glasses come off his face he's
holding his face
i'm like
so shocked at what i had done
the stunt guy comes up because it wasn't
your [ __ ] fault man i saw your foot
slip said [ __ ] shoes fault wasn't
your fault wasn't you i i'm just going
i'm so sorry silver comes running up
tony comes running up and damon wayans
gets up off the ground and goes i'm okay
i'm okay i'm all right let's go let's do
it again i'm all right tony goes no we
got that we're moving on i thought i was
gonna get fired on my very first day of
my first big you punched damon wayans in
the face
yeah on your first day of work on the
huge blockbuster movie
yeah and then the bruce willis story on
that let me tell you that this is cool
you're asking about being starstruck so
here we are it's my big scene
it's the big scene of the movie really i
mean it turned out to be everyone
remembers the scene
and i'm in this pool
inside and as you know michael this
happens to you because you're such a
[ __ ] movie star no one you always
come last to set i know you
like yeah the star comes last everyone's
got to be there they're wrong
so here i am
and there
he is his name's bruce willis hadn't met
him he comes walking up he's got a
t-shirt on
he's just comes [ __ ] walking up he's
got a couple people i i'll never forget
it tony comes over they start talking
and then they start coming into my area
where i'm gonna be you know it's cause
really my scene and there's another
actor playing the piano really great
comedic actor i can't remember his name
right now anyway it comes up to me
it doesn't look at me really and tony
goes hey bruce this is ken he goes hey
that's all i said was hey i go hey bruce
really nice to meet you okay so let's do
the scene so we're doing the scene we're
just [ __ ] doing the scene and willis
isn't telling me anything i'm not i'm
just doing my thing my god i've
auditioned for this part like you did
with clint i i i'm ad-libbing a little
bit i'm having a cigarette and punch him
and all that and then it comes time for
him to kill me this took two days
and now we're into day two and he's
gonna break my nose and i'm gonna i'm
gonna die and willis goes
okay so when i and he never called me
kim or my name just him i was just him
so when i hit him you know when i punch
him he's gonna fall into the pool
and that'll be that and michael i went
i i
i don't want to [ __ ] fall under the
pool takeout in my head i don't want to
so i called tony over
i said tony nothing for nothing
i don't see it that way he goes what do
you mean he goes i don't i don't see me
flying into the pool
he goes well how do you see it i go well
can we just do one
he goes sure she goes hey bruce bruce
we're going to do one for kim we're
going to do one for kevin sure all all
right he [ __ ] goes and he and i fell
right on my ass michael like a 10 year
old boy
and then i flopped back
and the camera's still rolling willa
showed me this later and everyone is
laughing their [ __ ] heads off
they're clapping they're laughing and
tony comes over and goes i think we got
it i think we got it and won well let's
go that was pretty [ __ ] good and we
did
we did a couple close-ups and [ __ ] but
no that was it one take a couple cameras
i fell on my ass like a little boy and
then i flopped back they couldn't
believe that i could fall on my butt
like that and stay straight like a tree
and then
anyway
that was my bruised ruler wow so you
impressed bruce
i think so
because we've become buddies we've done
a couple since then
and i always like hanging with him he
loves my wife
i haven't seen him in 10 years probably
but
he uh
he's a good guy he's a really good guy
and he's battling something now that no
one wants to go through wow did you ever
meet someone that you were excited to
meet or work with and they just let you
down they weren't the guy that you
thought they would be
you don't have to say their name but
have you ever been on set where it's
like yeah i got to the point where i
won't say his name because i hear he's a
really nice guy now but back in the day
i was doing a movie with carrie anne
moss and i was the lead bad guy and she
with our our lead that i'm talking about
and
he just was a real [ __ ] he just
really was being rude to everybody and
one day he cut down a crew member and i
walked up to him and i whispered to him
i said i'm gonna [ __ ] knock you out
right now i'm gonna knock you out i'm
gonna [ __ ] hit you right in the face
if you don't clean up your act you're
just you're just so full of hubris and
[ __ ] these people love you why why
are you behaving like this it's just
inexcusable and he looked at me and he
walked away and he was better for the
next next week and a half or what i just
said i'm gonna [ __ ] punch right in
the face i don't care if i go to jail
wow i'm i'm gonna knock you out because
i couldn't take it anymore i don't i'm
not i'm not i mean i'm far from perfect
you know mike but i gotta tell you the
one thing that i learned from my dad is
you stick up for people
that need sticking up for it you [ __ ]
stick you you stick up against the bully
because
it shouldn't happen there's way too much
bullying going on in this planet right
now and
yeah wow only once though i don't think
i ever remember how about you have you
run into once or twice there's been a
couple of bullies um bully directors but
not many i think i think i've probably
had two or three in my life where i just
said hey
you know i don't i didn't snap at him
but i just said
hey
hold on a second hang on this is not how
we do things here no
it was just he was uh making one of the
actresses uncomfortable
uh the director he was
bar all right you're gonna be over here
and you're gonna go okay and he grabs
her arm goes and i'm no no no you're
gonna go over here and i go whoa stop
stop stop and everybody looked at me i
go what what are you doing you guys
excuse me i go isn't this supposed to be
like a teamwork here we're trying to
figure it out you're just grabbing her
arm and moving her here you're not even
asking us what we're doing you're just
barking orders and acting like a macho
guy over here
and he goes oh so we have one of those
guys on set i go yeah
we have one of those guys
and then he was cooler he was way way
cooler they need a calling out every
once in a while and i just he just i
could feel it myself getting
uncomfortable and i was like i can't
work like this i can't be uncomfortable
like this i got to say something
and uh it's been it was it was
uncomfortable but i i picture you like a
good leader on set you want everybody to
have fun you want everybody to you know
thanks man and i i finally you know you
know me i'm like you i'm a character
actor i
you get all the funny [ __ ] a lot and i i
love comedy so much and when people find
out that i'm actually pretty funny once
in a while
which i which i love but i'm telling you
after sons was over
shortly thereafter a couple years later
there was a a series called bad blood
yes people love bad blood yeah it was a
huge [ __ ] on netflix and rogers and and
city up in
city tv up in canada and to be called in
on that and to be number one on the call
sheet
and they hire anthony lapaglia who was a
buddy of mine of paul cervino
these guys did it for a lot less money
than they normally get but the scripts
were so unbelievable based on the true
story
anthony played vito rizzuto a real crime
boss one of the biggest crime bosses in
the world let alone just canada from
montreal so he's playing a real guy
i played a fictional guy even though
between you and me now that it's over
he was based on a real guy who's um he's
still incarcerated so we couldn't we
couldn't really talk about him too much
but right i mean we had to change his
name his ethnicity the whole thing but
i'm telling you to be number one on the
call sheet and then after it was over to
have the actors and the actresses and
and producers just come up and go hey
man
way to go you you you really uh
you really did number one you really did
and i i did i cared about everybody and
i did the best i could in and making
everything comfortable but when it was
time to work
we [ __ ] worked man there's no there's
no dipsy doodling this is do you do you
stress do you get anxiety do you put
pressure on yourself that's not
that is unnecessary do you uh fight
through things do you do how do you deal
with all that stuff or are you just mr t
that's a great question i i didn't know
but i'm i'm full of anxiety i mean i i i
have a shrink that i see once in a while
and he's amazing he's in pasadena and he
really he calls me he called me early in
our sessions he would call me
king kong
no because i [ __ ] bursted in the room
i'd never been to a shrink before in my
life
and i burst into those zones do i pay
now i pay you now where do i sit what do
i how are you today
you just you just kind of said that
you can you sit wherever you want and
we'll worry about the payment later you
want it now in a check check check like
normally
a guy
you want this now we're going to keep
this a secret you want us now and keep
it straight you and me does it go
anywhere oh my [ __ ] being miked no no
so you know so he called me king kong
because he really and part of my anxiety
uh was coming
from i'm i'm so recognizable now
and the charities that i love doing or
it's [ __ ] on man it's on and i like
you do three or four cons a year maybe
you do more i mean i get asked to do
them a lot i'll go to a few my charities
make us money i make a little bit it's a
fun to see fans for me is it's draining
but in a good good way like i love my
fans
uh my people that like my work or
whatever but i was really um
going off the deep end with uh
stressing out about my career because it
just kept going up and up and up and
it's what i've always wanted and i like
where i'm at but i i uh
you know i needed to
calm down and breathe and
and slow down a bit and i think i
learned to do that what was it that you
noticed about yourself that you didn't
like that got you into therapy what was
it was it the little things what were
those things that you or maybe your wife
and maybe diana diana right oh for sure
oh for sure diet diet would notice um
you know what it was michael it was this
kind of [ __ ] where i'd never
i'd never
i was always proud of just being me
whether you know me from movies or from
playing football with me when i was 17 i
was pretty proud of being me and i
stopped kind of doing that for a while
i started knowing that if i was going to
a house party
i thought they would expect me to talk
about my movies or talk about bruce
willows or talk about
sons or sons and so i put all this
[ __ ] into my head so i would be just
kind of
moving too fast
moving too fast and so i i think i've
learned to try and slow down what do you
do also sorry michael what do you do to
slow down
um just let it happen let everything
instead of trying to think about making
everybody happy all the time
you know my one of my sayings that i use
michael is i can't tell you how to
succeed but i can tell you how to fail
by trying to please everyone
and
you know i've always looked at myself as
being a really fortunate [ __ ]
i've worked really hard for my career
but i've been really fortunate with my
friends
bill fichner who you worked with
he loves you you guys are best friends
he says he on the podcast was like yeah
me and cozy pretty much talk every day
we're always on the phone
yeah we do i mean he says it
the best like is how weird is it to meet
your best friend at 40. you know when we
did black hawk down we were both like
40.
and you know we met each other and it
was over because we are the same kind of
guy anyway he loves you and i think i've
just really enjoyed
my my life and so i really look out for
the underdog i think and i really
sometimes try too hard to make people
happy
because i know they're happy to see me
but when i'm around
guys like you or fickner or guys that i
just can be myself around without trying
it's the best time for kim coach so
that's what it is it's trying to be
yourself and not let not trying to
people please too much
kind of trying to breathe and do your
thing yeah
yeah um you got this movie coming out or
it's out now it's out on digital and on
demand and i saw the trailer for this
and it looked intense as [ __ ]
yeah and uh neon lights yeah now you get
to work or she gets you get yeah you get
to work with brenna brenna coats your
daughter and you know a lot of times you
hear you know somebody's working with
her daughter this she's like a star
like she's she's went to tisch she's
done so much theater she is she knows
what the hell she's doing yeah she's the
real deal this kid she um you know dai
and i my wife and i we we didn't
push our kids away or to
anything when they were growing up it
was letting them discover what they
liked and loved and
reading they're both so smart kyla you
know she's trying to save america god
bless her she works in la county with
janason she's a deputy supervisor she's
a big shot and she's with mental health
and
the sheriff's department the firemen and
homeless i mean she's she's in it in la
county 12 million people she's got a big
job and she loves it and she really
really
is caring about america in the right way
being such a liberal it's uh she's got a
lot of work ahead of her we're proud of
her brenna who's as smart as kyla
she was an actor from four five six
years old i mean she just knew it she
was shy she's beautiful she's funny
anyway so she auditions for tish
uh from her high school in pasadena she
gets in
uh she's in new york and you know
michael it's like come on [ __ ] off it's
like 65 grand a year
and that doesn't even buy you a
starbucks
and if her dad is not on sons of anarchy
she's not going to new york she's going
to victoria or saskatchewan or seattle
somewhere you know i i couldn't afford
you know come on right right i happen to
be lucky to be on a big tv show and i'm
making money so fine she goes there four
years
at the end of the fourth year michael
they do a
they do a
it's a one act 90 minute play sarah de
la brand new play called the wolves
so all the seniors it's about nine girls
on a soccer team
a mom comes in at the end of the play
and they had one showing of what they
were doing this is the final project
here she is saying bye
i flew i saw it diana couldn't go i'm in
the audience
i am
so blown away at all the girls we're all
crying at the end this is a juggernaut
play and they knew it
cut two
six months later they're finally gonna
do the wolves in poughkeepsie and from
poughkeepsie it's gonna go up broadway
if it's any good it'll go to broadway so
brenda has to re-audition and she's
going through all the stress
all the stress same part she's perfect
for it and i go i'm telling you right
now brenna and this is what you and i
had to deal with michael i i still do
but they're gonna look for a name her
part was one of the three leads of the
nine girls they're gonna look for a name
so don't don't feel bad if you don't get
it i got a good feeling about it but you
did you know so she did one and she did
a call back all these producers were
sitting there whatever whatever then we
had to wait two weeks
and she finally got the call that the
part was hers cut to a summer of
poughkeepsie couldn't get a ticket goes
to the duke theater couldn't get a
ticket all these movie stars are
starting to see this play the walls the
wolves the walls it gets called um one
of the greatest plays in new york in the
past 25 new york times new york times
correct
and so brenna gets called out on all
anyway they end up winning an ob and a
drama desk award for the ensemble of all
the actors on it all nine girls win
these incredible awards she goes you
know
right to another play in san diego
another place somewhere else then she
comes and doesn't play with dad i did
jerusalem by jazz butterworth i almost
died on stage every night mark rylance
was doing it again right now in london i
flew to see him we had dinner i saw it
twice hugs all around he gave me the
baton four years ago when i was
preparing to play this guy it took a
year to prepare the accent went to
london five times the whole deal is a
long story but brenna was in that play
with dad cut to this moving neon lights
michael
when this movie and it was during the
pandemic nothing's happening early fall
2020. my agent in canada i've always
told gail that's why i've never fired
her i love her to death i've hired more
american american agents over the years
but i'm with a really good one now
sharing conan i love her to death
uh my management company's pretty cool
too maine state anyway
i get this call from gail she goes
you're not gonna do this movie i go
what's it called neon lights why
it's just really dark it's it's i can't
get through it i said well send it to me
so they sent it to me
and sure enough it's about mental health
right and it's about it's about it's a
psychological thriller slash horror
small cast it's in one man mansion the
house has a character on its own i play
a guy i can't say too much about it
because it's a very surprise when you
watch the movie
anyway there was a perfect part for me
and a perfect part for brenna and i had
to read it twice to really understand
what this guy dana abraham who wrote it
and starred in and was talking about
i said i would do it they said can we
have brenda to us and you'd have to call
her and see if she'll she like she read
it she plays a shrink she's never played
a part like that before she's really
like an angel in this movie
um she says yes so we're working
together for the first time michael we
had our premiere about a month ago in
hamilton at another premiere in la i
wasn't able to make the la one i saw the
one in in brenna went to bow she's a
second build she's above the title with
me and dana
everyone's so good this movie is so
scary it's it's just it's the reviews
have been so unbelievable because it's
about mental health yeah and it's right
up my alley too because it's got that
psychological
horror
tech tycoon clay imani retreats to an
off-the-grid location in search of
meaning and peace with disconnected
siblings and their offspring only to be
caught in a bone-chilling killing spree
within his new estate
it's just like
the trailer you're like what the hell
it's just it's like this is what i the
kind of stuff i watch
so i'm i'm excited for this i can't wait
to watch this well and who you're
talking about clay armani is played by
dana abraham he's the lead of this movie
i happen to play his uh his stepfather
and we're going to stop right there i
can't say myself
because it is um i was
ruse bae hidari who directed it this
beautiful iranian canadian canadian
iranian boy he's so talented he's just
so he was so great with the actors and
all mass soul shields all you know
tested every day all that stuff that we
had to do and still do really um because
of this pandemic but he was beautiful
and i'm stunned at the music i'm stunned
at how i mean i was i helped produce it
so i got to see all the all the cuts and
i would give notes and i listened to
every single note that i had i'm very
very objective i'm not a subjective guy
it's all about the
greater being of this movie and beats
and what scenes are too long or what
scenes don't work and they did a great
job and like i said it's um it's killing
it on video and demand is everywhere now
yeah yeah neon lights digital
uh
demand
go see it i mean if if you're me and you
love horror movies uh and it's much more
than that and i just i can't tell
exactly what your character is but it's
it's something i i don't want to say
dark but
oh no you can say dark it's pretty dark
but can i just say one thing here about
about who i played denver cain
when i read it
um i had to change some things because
it was way too much on this side of the
railroad tracks right for me as you can
imagine michael with these cheekbones
and his eyes and
and i play a lot i play a lot of bad i
play a lot of bad boys and i'm really
careful with my bad boys and this guy i
said oh i'm playing him but it's got to
be this because you need to bring some
like why
why is he even in this movie if he's
just that way it's just too boring too
scary one note right right one note and
they went oh my god yeah yeah so he's
mesmerizing
he's methodical
he's kind
he's
dark as [ __ ] and he it's like a like
he's like a python he just sucks you
right in and then he's going to bite you
right and then see those are the best
kind of villains those are the best kind
of dark characters i mean look i played
lex luthor and if you people loved they
loved him in the beginning if you get
them to like you or love you or have
those moments instead of being one note
it makes the character so much more can
we talk about that for a minute you were
so [ __ ] good
thanks man it was like you were so good
in that you did the best thing in that
show i mean the show was good it lasted
for 18 000 years but you were so good i
saw maybe five ten shows
and um
you were having a blast and i can't
remember but you hurt your back didn't
you am i making this yeah i've had a lot
of surgeries and stuff through playing
ice hockey my whole life and just kind
of like you know like yeah you're
[ __ ] there yeah so you know i had
some issues with the back over the years
hasn't been fun but like you know i've
been doing a lot better i've been doing
a lot better so i've been just trying to
take care of myself and uh you know so
now if i can get the anxiety under
control coach how are you doing that
right that's all right you know it's
it's like i i just turned 50. do you
remember turning 50 yeah
was it weird for you or just another
number it was the beginning of the best
part of my life because it was literally
two months before i started sons of
anarchy
i i just the truth i had my 50th
birthday party and and literally
like two seconds later
i'm cast as tig traeger and i said to my
wife i guess i better do this and she
was like on her knees going please
please please
i went sure can we just have a paycheck
once a week that we know something i
love it i love it
all right this is this is called
[ __ ] talking with kim coats these are my
patrons they give back to the show
they're unbelievable go to patreon.com
inside you join patreon i'll send you a
message thanks for supporting the show i
love you these are from the top tiers
they're asking this is rapid fire
yeah so you go
chris r how did it feel playing a nut
like tig on sons of anarchy
mental
mental i mean i
i just said to kurt sutter i turned it
down i turned it down he said why i said
he's too psychotic he hadn't showed me
he goes no no tig's gonna be psychotic
for sure but he's gonna have a heart of
gold he's gonna be funny he's gonna be a
moral compass of the club he's gonna be
psycho he's gonna be this he's gonna be
that he's gonna be and you can ride and
you're gonna love riding and just please
come along for the ride and i did and
i'm so glad i did but i've never
played anyone like him before wow jeremy
c what would be your favorite role to
take on if you could do anything or have
you done it already
oh my god that's a great question
no i haven't done it already but i've
been lucky right to be a character actor
i get to really act i get to change it
up i get to cut my hair grow it get fat
get skinny have accents have a limp
i mean honest to god wear armani or wear
nothing and show my stomach off i mean
i i'm just so lucky to be a character
actor i get offered all kinds of [ __ ]
and i'm loving it i'm loving every
single thing i get offered and i say yes
to it by the way do you work out a lot
i do i have do you think that really
helps with with in life in general to
keep your body moving to keep strong
yeah because i'm flying all the time i'm
in hotel rooms all the time i'm on
different pillows all the time i'm
filming all the time and if you don't
take time to bike or walk or a few
weights here and there at my age i'm in
my 60s now you you're gonna you're gonna
break down and so i really am trying not
to break down and working out helps me
david h who's someone you've worked with
that you expected them to be one way and
they turned out to be completely
different in a good way i hope
i i was really uncertain about kevin
costner i got to tell you he's again one
of my best friends now and he turned out
to be the kindest smart
um even though he didn't direct water
world he kind of did and then open range
he did direct and michael gambon and i
played the two league bad guys in that
and i would spend night after night at
kevin's house uh in the in the beautiful
rocky mountains up in canmore alberta
watching him edit smoking pot with him
every night and watching him edit
and edit and have a glass of wine and
then learn from him um
i was stunned at how warm kevin is to
everybody and how smart he is if you
[ __ ] him he'll he'll he'll put you in a
headlock and he won't let go
but he's uh he turned out to be like
what a what a jewel kevin costner for
sure wow legend
joey mack loved you as declan in bad
blood did you prep for the role by
studying any iconic movies like the
godfather or goodfellas
no i didn't prep it with that but i read
a lot of books
and their
bad blood was called in blood in in in
blood or in
in business i think it's called business
and blood the book the true book that we
bought the rights to to do the six part
first year mini-series that would turn
into a two-year thing so i did a lot of
reading did a lot of reading about
montreal did a lot of reading about the
early years of
being a gangster in montreal and
all the bike gangs and
all the people that were you know i read
all the truth stuff and then i
incorporated that into my character for
sure ray h what do you enjoy about your
work
i love what i do
i don't know how many people
can say
they love their job
um
and i get
paid well for it i don't even know why i
i've never worried about money michael
to be perfectly honest with you it's
just come to me i guess after all these
years and
but i was so
wanting to be the best actor i could be
in all that theater and not getting paid
but i didn't care
and now it's paid off because
people
people befriend me
maybe because i'm kim coates but
boy this you like hanging with me
because
i think i'm a really good actor and
i love listening like when you and i
work together i'll never forget
listening to you like listen if you
listen to people on set then then you
won't act and you're just going to feel
it's just going to come out of you if
you don't listen you plan everything
well then that's called acting and the
camera's going to see it and you'll
never be at the level you and i've got
to so um yeah man i just love my job
that's it sophie m any fond memories
from working on skin walkers
sure
[ __ ] skin walkers you know why
i'm gonna tell you why that movie could
have been so good
stan winston
what a great great loved him makeup
artist i mean he's won a gazillion
oscars
no one was better at his job than him
and
for himself
i wanted to do one more movie about
werewolves and he was going to design
the suit it wasn't going to be cgi he
wanted the actors to grow into their
suit right um jason bear elia katayus me
the three lead i mean so that movie when
i read it michael it was r
it was an r rated film and it was so
good and so dark and so unbelievable we
all signed on and i'll never forget
getting to set up in toronto
and all the leads were there the
directors there were all ready to go
and they were giving oh they said oh
there's some rewrites
and
we got handed the script
and we started to read it and i'll never
forget after about page 20 i left the
table and i laid on the floor
i i was so depressed
at what they had done to turn this into
a pg-13 light
light arena oh boy of a film i was so
depressed that all the money people that
put all this money in they're going no
this is the new script and contest and i
and jason bear he couldn't run away we
were still gonna do it but i knew this
[ __ ] movie was gonna fail and it did
now i'm i love that this person gal guy
i couldn't remember the name that you
said
that they love this movie because there
we go
we have some fans with this film but i'm
telling you straight up it could have
been way way better had they stuck to
their guns and not being afraid to make
it a restricted film because it was so
much better
you know i always i love talking to you
it's been forever but you speak your
mind you have unbelievable stories
you're so down to earth i miss you i
love seeing your face
this is and neon lights is out on demand
and digital please check it out if you
love horror if you love psychological
stuff
you're in for a a fun little movie here
and yeah you better if you if you drink
you better have a drink in front of you
if you eat you better have some popcorn
in front of you because you're gonna be
nervous watching this film it's a very
nervy [ __ ] film rosenbaum you're
amazing bro uh what you do is amazing i
think as an artist
stands on its own billy loved working
with you and the neighbors so much i'm
jealous yeah and you guys we got to do
something together we got eventually
they'll do something together i would
love that that would be a real treat you
know no treat bro
hey back at you i love you good luck
with everything man loves my success
big love
you got to live and learn
do you remember that song no that was
from like the late 90s or early 2000s
you've got to live and learn it was a
terrible song
terrible song was it yeah it sounds
inspiring does it why you you've got it
you're not you're not doing linus linus
morrison are you no
what was that song you live
you learn i kind of like that that's a
good song that's a good song she doesn't
miss she had some tunes yeah thanks kim
coates for coming on the podcast i loved
having you on you were a freaking treat
i love your stories
and uh yeah great great guest uh what
else can we say um you know everything
was said in the beginning um
appreciate everybody's support this
podcast is you know we're not the
biggest podcast in the world but uh we
we could definitely use your help and we
appreciate your help go to patreon.com
inside of you you want to join patreon
become a patron of mine i'll message you
back uh go to the inside of you online
store for cool merch
as i said in the beginning um later in
the year i'll be going to like san fran
uh columbus
pittsburgh for some cons in late late
november or december
and uh also i want to give a shout out
to all my friends out there have
supported me in the last few weeks i've
been dealing with a lot of anxiety and
uh my patrons and everyone listening uh
it's life man it's life ryan we all go
through it but we do
yeah sometimes you just feel hopeless
sometimes you just feel like man what
the [ __ ] what am i doing
i honestly i was on the wrong meds and
when you're on the raw meds your mind
goes to weird places like what am i
doing here
why what what is there why why
i had no like nothing part of this being
a human too yes and you just have to
know that this is your mind
it's not real these thoughts aren't real
it's not a reality many times what are
the facts yeah what are the facts here
and uh then you start to go hey you know
and people say this all the time but
saying your gratitudes before you go to
bed when you wake up i took a hike and
at the top of the hill there's the
beautiful view of
los angeles and i just sat there and i
said hey
god thanks
thanks for life thanks for this planet
thanks for and i just started doing it
it just it made me feel better it's just
being grateful you know do you do that
not enough
not enough but it does help
there's something with your mind when
your mind actually when your brain hears
that when you keep when you keep saying
it you're like rewiring your your mind
yeah you know so it's good so thanks for
all the support the love uh let's give a
shout out to all the top tier
patrons these are folks that are the top
tier that give a lot to the podcast and
really keep it afloat ryan knows many of
them by memorization i don't know just
that back half is a little tough
yeah should we start working on the back
half
yeah i've got the first several down
yeah you do
all right here we do do we want any
particular voice today
um
yours
my voice yeah yes okay
uh nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p robert b
jason w sophie m kristen k not to be
confused with
kristin crook correct raj c joshua d cjp
jennifer n stacy l jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e l dan supremo
99 more ramirez santiago m chad w leanne
p janine r maya p matty s belinda n
chris h dave h sheila g brad d
ray h so far you know these tab of the t
tom n liliana a talia m betsy d chad l
marion megkay big stevie w angel m
angel
i lived in a place and there was near
there was a place called angel mounds so
remember angel m angel mounds
rhiannon
angel man sounds like a euphemism for a
child's poop that's all i'll say
all right rhiannon c
corey k
dev nixon
michelle a jeremy c andy t gabinator
david c john [ __ ]
john b brandy d
yvore camille s the chief
the chief the chief
joey m
just one chief just the one
joey m design otg eugene and liam nikki
g corey kdb
patricia heather l think heather
locklear
jake b think jake bucy
that will help you
megan t
i don't know what you could do there
making tea making tea what are you doing
in the kitchen making tea
mel s
melis
mls oh boy major league soccer mls
orlando c
orlando klum
well uh speaking of mls the orlando
soccer team is orlando city so that's
orlando c okay so you can remember c
caroline r uh-huh caroline r
oh that's a tough one where are you
going i'm going down to carolina i'm
going to carolina there you go
christine s
sure
christina's awesome
christine s awesome memorize that
sarah smile s sarah s
eric hmm
yup that's a tough one jennifer r
uh-huh
jennifer rarner
shaney shane r
emma
r
emma roberts oh there you go there you
go robert jeremy v
jeremy's vulcan jeremy's vegan jeremy's
vegan
andrew andrew m
andrew m robert g
robert g
z twitchy zadoichi77
sure
uh andreas
andreas and fault
andreas oh and then
hmm
oracle
chris r
chris rock
michael f michael fassbender huh
karina n
uh-huh i don't know karina it's a nice
name green hi karina i've talked to
karina we assumed big group of us zoomed
i liked it
samantha w michelle d
amanda r i know i know michelle d in
real life okay there you go yeah amanda
r
amanda r
amanda are your
amanda
r
amanda lovecraft e
amanda s
uh-huh
and jen b genbee
and b it's going to be tough for we'll
see how that's going to be tough those
are the top tier patrons those are the
folks that really help the podcast but
you know you can give anything back to
the podcast and it helps it really truly
does thank you for listening today
thank you for listening every week thank
you even if you don't know a guest and
you listen it helps the podcast write a
review subscribe all that stuff say
hello to ryan online say hello to me
um i appreciate you all i love you
dearly and thank you for listening this
podcast um from michael rose's mom here
in the hollywood hills of california i'm
bryan tayes as well a little wave to the
camera a little peace sign uh
guys be good to yourselves be good to
yourselves and uh we'll see you in a
week